aujourd'hui je vous parle audio je vais
être gardées on va parler dodo va
s'appeler 07 plaisir à nos oreilles
après la vague française qui s'appelle
focale focale je sais pas si vous
connaissez
si vous êtes audiophiles vous connaissez
très très très très normalement voilà
allez on se fait des petits points et
petits réglages à nantes du collège
focale si vous connaissez pas vous
devriez parce que c'est une très bonne
marque qui propose des produits vraiment
hyper intéressant et là on est sur un
produit à moins de 100 euros chez focale
ça c'est bien c'est très intéressant
on est sur le sphère wireless qui est
sorti en début d'année il ya une sphère
qui est sorti il ya déjà longtemps et là
on est sur royan s
on n'est pas sans doute roux ailleurs
l'ex pourquoi parce que vous avez
certifié je voyais communiquent entre
eux grâce à un fil néanmoins c'est
plutôt cool ça marche bien alors je vous
fais un petit peu le brief pour vous
compreniez que sont ces écouteurs dit
s'adresse aux nomades aux personnes qui
aiment se déplacer dans les transports
en commun qui dans la rue qui se
baladent parce qu'il faut du sport aussi
ses pensées pratique parce que bull
calais comme ça dans vos oreilles
septième match tombe bien c'est vraiment
vraiment cool en plus vous les enlevez
up
elles sont là elles se cassent pas la
figure elles sont bien qu'il n'a pas
assez bien
on est donc sur des produits pour des
personnes qui sont plutôt dynamiques
sont plutôt mobile plutôt urbains voire
même pas forcément on peut aussi vouloir
courir la campagne
ça me paraît logique d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas donc ces écouteurs sont faites pour
toutes ces personnes là et surtout ça
vous permet d'avoir un ticket d'entrée
chez focale sur du wireless à 99 euros
et c'est vraiment là tout l'intérêt de
ce produit alors ce produit il a des
points vraiment très positif il ya des
trucs sont vraiment cool
il a aussi des points un peu plus
négatifs on peut pas tout avoir à 99
euros ça paraît quand même relativement
normal je vous détailler un peu sage et
vous dire moi ce que j'en pense comment
je les trouve et puis au final si vous
voulez acheter un casque à moins de 100
euros est ce que ça vaut le coup d'aller
sur ses focales sphère wireless en 2019
woods
[Musique]
je vous présente rapidement les
packagings bon alors voilà ça c'est la
boîte de base normalement hier ça à
l'intérieur mais là je les enlever pour
les besoins de la vidéo package sympa
simple efficace centre qui marche bien
il ya un côté un peu premium vous ouvrez
votre petite boîte c'est simple page des
petites mousses ce qu'on va trouver en
plus de ces écouteurs c'est normal vous
les avez achetés c'est c'est petit étui
très sympathique pour les emmener se
donne vraiment un côté premium l'idée
c'est que lorsque vous partez en
déplacement et vous n'allez pas les
avoir autour de votre cou
eh bien vous avez un endroit pour les
ranger qui ne risque pas de s'abîmer
ils sont protégés il ya un côté un peu
classieuse et pense un petit étui à
bijoux c'est sympa vous avez ensuite des
embouts pour toutes les oreilles soient
des embouts en silicone soit les envoie
à mémoire de forme enfin vraiment bien
ya différentes tailles
ça c'est cool vous avez de quoi elle
recharge et ça c'est pour l'humidité on
s'en fout c'est un petit peu et puis
vous avez une doc voilà c'est sympa
c'est joli je trouve que focal a fait un
beau boulot niveau du packaging
en plus d'avoir des produits sains pas
là j'ai une petite couleur un peu
violine très jolie en plus avoir un beau
packaging a produit sympa on a un truc
cool voilà j'aime j'aime ça je vote je
vote pour
je dis oui bravo focal enfin c'est
toujours un peu compliqué de venir
parler d'audio comme ça dans la mesure
où je peux pas vous le faire écouter
pour vous puissiez vous en rendre compte
maintenant il ya plusieurs points le
premier point c'est les produits ce qui
s'adapte bien est ce qu'on arrive à les
posséder facilement dans ses oreilles tu
es là pour le coup je vous dis oui alors
ça dépend de nous
ça dépend bien évidemment car elle a
parlé dépend évidemment des ombres vous
allez choisir pour qu'il soit dit a été
complètement la forme de vos oreilles ça
dépend aussi des oreilles de chacun des
gens chez qui des fois ce genre de
produit n'ira pas d'autres chez qui ça
ira parfaitement bien chez moi c'est
cool dès que vous avez trouvé la bonne
position vous les mettez vous détournez
légèrement vous les mettez dans vos
oreilles et l'a déjà comme ça vous avez
une bonne isolation passive alors là en
parlant pour comme ça c'est plus
compliqué pour moi parce que ça bouge un
peu j'ai besoin de mon temps a fait du
bien une bonne isolation passive donc
vous n'êtes pas avoir une réduction
brute qui va être aussi bonne qu avec
une réduction active qui me paraît aussi
normal sinon ça vaudrait pas le coup
d'avoir des casques à réduction active
néanmoins la réduction passive et de
bien et je pense notamment que vous êtes
dans un milieu plutôt une banlieue
plutôt bruyant et transports en commun
les choses comme ça ça vous isole un peu
légèrement mais ça marche bien donc ça
c'est un point positif
entre poids qui est très important c'est
le confort je trouve que on a vraiment
des produits qui ont confort une fois de
plus vous le dit
en effet comme ça tournait un peu tac
vous le positionner vous avez position
de confort donc ça c'est franchement
cool excusez moi ces jeux des quizz un
peu il fait 42 or ces défis très chaud
très chaud passer pour la petite
anecdote
donc voila vous venez les passionnés
sensation de confort qui est bien
position qui est bien on sent quasiment
pas ça autour du cou on pourrait se dire
là j'ai un truc un peu plus gros malgré
tout vous le sentez pas ça pose pas de
problème donc ça c'est bien pour tout
vous dire avec ce casque c'est du
bonheur du bluetooth 4 points il est
compatible
ap tx2 qualcomm on a une qualité audio
qui pour moi est honnête et correct
c'est assez neutre c'est pas quelque
chose de type et mais malgré tout il
faut que ça fait le job alors une fois
de plus on va repositionner les choses
dans leur bonne catégorie on est serein
produits à moins de 100 euros on n'aura
pas elle la meilleure qualité on n'aura
pas la meilleure qualité de son plu
trouve en tout cas chez focale par
contre vu son segment de prix vu ce
positionnement tarifaire je trouve que
c'est un produit qui à 89 euros et bien
et honnête est vraiment réglo souvent
vue sur différents review ddd comparatif
par rapport aux airs pop pour moi ce ne
sont pas tous et même produit déjà du
travail en leur faveur sont défendus qui
sont vraiment différentes mais en plus
de ça c'est pas une qualité la qualité d
apple sera nettement supérieur néanmoins
je trouve que là ça fait le job focale
fait un bon boulot vu le positionnement
ils ont dû faire des choix des coupes
tarifaire forcément un moment tu ne peux
pas pas mettre ça l'agacé tout coûte un
peu d'argent mais je trouve qu'il ya des
choix stratégiques qui ont été faits qui
sont les bons les écouteurs une qualité
qui sont vraiment vraiment correct et on
peut se regarder et vous le montrez un
petit peu pour vous puissiez vous en
rendre compte
voilà vous avez votre petit scooter
classique hélas là vous avez un côté
pour coter bass reflex
ça permet de faire ressortir un peu les
basses à optimiser le sont optimisés la
partie basse de votre de votre et
twitter permettant d'optimiser les
basses de façon très naturelle vraiment
le le focus café sur ce casque c'est
pour moi un son flat plat naturel et si
vous voulez avoir reçu qu'un peu plus de
grave
eh bien vous avez une possibilité vous
avez ici des petits boutons alors de
petits boutons vous me direz à quoi ils
servent
regardez vous avez un petit bouton pour
baisser le volume d'eau pour monter le
volume et à boutons ici pour me remettre
la pause
lorsqu'on fait un appui long vous allez
passer au morceau suivant lorsque tu un
appui long run et aux morceaux
précédents
et lorsque vous voulez activer le sont
avec les coalisés a changé de système
vous avez deux thèmes les quoi l'isr
soual côté place soit côté l'oms
vous allez voir plus de grave et bien
voulait s'appuyer les deux boutons aux
extrémités en même temps pendant trois
secondes et vous allez switcher d'un
mode à l'autre
alors pour savoir sur quel modèle vous
êtes et bien vous mettez vous écouter
vous faire tout de suite
il ya quand même une différence d'un
côté vous allez voir quand même plus
deux mois il ce que je veux dire quoi ça
secoue et justement il ya un mois deux
choses que je regrettais principalement
sur ce sur ce sur ce produit là alors il
a fallu une fois de plus faire des coups
peut pas tout faire des coupes franches
au niveau du budget je pense
la première chose c'est lorsque vous
avez votre casque sur les oreilles comme
ça bien positionné bien en place hop
comme ça et bien sûr que c'est pas
forcément intuitif d'aller trouver vos
boutons parce que vous allez chercher
par ici alors avec un peu d'habitude et
bien vous savez sur quel bouton vous
êtes mais c'est vrai que la juda mince
quand je commence à me dire qu'elle sait
tient un bâton mais ça mouille le savoir
c'est de le prendre de mettre là et de
le voir voilà donc collaborer dans un
sens que vous remettez la nuit dans
l'autre sens donc voilà il faut vous
prendre ses petites habitudes
une fois vous l'avez prise ce qui n'est
pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup de temps
et bien ça marche mais c'est vrai que de
vivre à spa hyper intuitive
deuxième point c'est que vous n'avez pas
de l'application dédiée j'aurais aimé
que focale nous fasse une application
dédiée pour ios ou android où on puisse
venir régler son équaliseur je trouve
que le système d'appui long sur les deux
boutons pour changer de l'equal isr
c'est pas forcément extraordinaire
c'est bien que ça existe donc je vais
pas cracher dans la soupe mais je trouve
que c'est sorti mieux autant
d'expériences utilisateurs d'aller plus
loin et d'avoir une application dédiée
pour pouvoir me régler sont les co
leaders donc ça ça aurait été bien c'est
peut-être des points d'amélioration sur
lesquels focale va travailler dans les
années à venir en tout cas pour
l'instant voilà c'est vraiment les deux
points de s'approcher
à côté de ça ce castola une fois de plus
son repositionnement ça dans sa tranche
tarifaire 99 euros c'est un très bon
produit je voulais une fois de plus la
qualité sonore est bien le confort est
cool pour aller courir c'est bien
l'autonomie et bien vous ne tardez à peu
près huit heures ce que nous annonce
focale et ils n'ont pas le montrent il
ya dessus 8h on est dans cette dans
cette fourchette là pour moi c'est un
gros point positif pour ce cas ce que là
si vous aimez à côté de ça laissons un
peu cheap et les sons qui vont être un
peu plus rock'n'roll qui sont plus typé
très clairement typée ça sera pas ce cas
cela qu'il nous faudra si vous voulez un
casque un peu passe partout qui va être
bon dans plein de styles différents sans
forcément venir se faire remarquer dans
un style plutôt que dans un autre et
bien celui là et bien c'est vraiment sa
qualité principale c'est effectivement
d'être d'être un peu passe partout voilà
je trouve bien il est cool si vous
intéresse si elle est dans la
description maintenant vous de me dire
que vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
ce petit casque là
intéressant oui lyon quand comment est
ce que vous l'avez essayé ce que vous
avez un produit che focal est ce que ça
vous intéresse des casques comme ça
wireless à moins de 100 euros si vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire et
on reparlera de focales dans quelques
jours on a plus gros casse la tester
mais ça c'est dans quelques jours donc
on pas louper abonnez vous dès
maintenant sur ce je vous embrasse mon
gros meco et à demain ciao
[Musique]